okay I'm Rick your wreck I'm a wreck
you're a wreck
I'm a wreck but I'm also wreck your
erect yes I figured that would attract
Bigfoot I mean I don't know about that
but you know I'll take whatever you can
give me because at this point we haven't
caught Bigfoot yet but this time we will
yes I believe no it's not about belief
have you ever hunted Bigfoot before no
no you haven't I have many times and
every time I go more of my friends
understand you understand I I think I do
you understand what's at stake here it
appears that you are taller than me yes
I am thank you for noticing always have
been but that's not the point your
shortness is nothing to do with what's
happening right now because I am gonna
make you a hero you know how are you
just grabbing willy-nilly
no I don't you're talking about I picked
up something off the ground you grab
something willy-nilly I only took two
thanks okay that's right what did you
take
tracking bullets in a trap God dear I
was gonna tell you not to take the
tracking bullets
I know there are each fine I was gonna
take care of all the tracking for you so
you didn't have to do any of the
tracking and all you had to focus on
give you items does it well give me the
tracking bullets you are predominantly
gonna be shooting shooting bang bang man
I know that your brain can handle shooty
shooty bang bang are you okay I am I'm
trying to give you bullets and it's not
letting me give you give me the bullets
uh well you know it's fine whatever keep
what you have
it'll be fine come in here grab a gun
there's quite a few rifles in here
there's some tracking bullets I'm gonna
take you can press f to turn on your
light I'm gonna take the meat you meet
up a meat wraps under here do you want
those traps yeah I'm gonna grab the
traps all right so no tracking bullets
just regular bullets yeah you focus on
the regular bullets now listen up and
listen close there's just what is the
signal clip I just said listen up and
listen close I'm sorry listen sorry
Bigfoot
I'm talking it's about to get dark
Bigfoot is only aggressive at night and
trust me when I say you don't have
nearly enough rectal real estate to
handle Bigfoot right now okay
okay Bigfoot means death pure and simple
so we need to arm ourselves and kill him
dead now pull out your gun oh [ __ ] those
moderately threatening okay good good
great you pulled out your gun so you
noticed that if you pull out your gun it
doesn't have any bullets so you got to
reload reload the bullets and you can
also switch your bullets from regular
bullets to tracking bullets with T but
you you just focus on regular bullets
all right useful gun nice regular
bullets you don't need to worry about
tracking right now
we're just gonna focus on shooting them
feel good feels good I feel like I'm a
hunter good cuz you are I mean you're
also being hunted but we're a hunter duo
of a sort so follow me I've got a map of
all the little locations that we need to
find in these woods
perfect perfect gonna get ammo it's
gonna get us more traps and hopefully if
you see any deer we're gonna kill the
deers too and then we're gonna take
their meat and use it for bait
understood understood I will eat the
deers don't eat the deer so you're
supposed to save the meat for the deers
to put in the traps so that we can
attract Bigfoot
okay so kill the deer and hands it's a
Bigfoot well I mean you can kill the
deer I'll handle all the handling cuz I
don't think you're capable of it
you're right I'm to erect I can't reach
things seven dog Oh wolf bang see it's
that easy and now I steal its meat thank
you thank you
delicious you're back with a gun to my
back no I was facing the other way I was
looking away okay good alright so
there's little more wolves because
they're like pack animals it was a fox
which is the opposite of a pack animal
you're right they're flying lonely yeah
they are more serious note actually do
keep an eye out for Bigfoot because this
early in the game I don't think
Bigfoot's gonna be charging at us
anytime soon but you know it
could happen so I'm sticking close yes
you're sticking close that's what I
serve us equals one Bigfoot not
necessarily pretty much a Bigfoot could
take a party of four but we sticking
together and using our wits are not
gonna be caught surprised
hey hey that's that's noise yeah that we
actually that actually spooked all that
looked like a person it's not a person
it's not a person it is a person oh yeah
that was a person yeah buh God yeah
there's an axe yeah take the first-aid
kit you can't take the axe I don't think
and not that it would do you any good
anyway because I don't think an axe is
gonna do anything in the face of Bigfoot
I don't know you can chop his foot off
you know let him know that you actually
found a Bigfoot that's always possible
but if we if if possible I think we're
gonna take Bigfoot whole that's a lot of
weight that's a lot of masses feet weigh
like 30 pounds each look I don't want to
cut Bigfoot's feet off that could just
be some guy named Larry with huge feet
we need the whole Bigfoot so that people
can know that we actually got Bigfoot
all right damn I think that was I think
that was it I think it was just the
first aid kit
I mean sawmills should have traps you
know so I'm trapped the trees to chop
them up is that what you really think
you need to trap a tree I mean they do
rat chains around them right they do
yeah but that's yeah that's fine
whatever yeah you got to stalk the trees
man you gotta you gotta be stealthy
about all right keep going follow me man
it really didn't want me to stay close
to you and I tried to separate me why
what do you mean it did what does that
mean I got stuck on a tree it did tried
to grapple me and I think it just got
something against trees man I don't
think trees are out to get you I don't
think trees need to be hunted down and I
definitely don't think trees need to be
trapped well they're put there pine
trees they they have needles so they
won't leave me alone what does having
needles have to do with leaving you
alone that doesn't make any sense
you're just saying nonsense well if they
had leaves they would leave me alone oh
sorry I was just trying to lighten the
mood
you know we're alone in the woods here
you know I could shoot you in the back
of the head no one would know the
difference then big Bluto come along eat
your corpse and then none would be the
wiser you just be dead I mean I
I would know the difference well you
wouldn't cuz you'd have a bullet in the
back of your head but do I cease to
exist
Thanks uh you know I don't know the
answer that that's kind of a theological
question that that's more of a like a
philosophical dilemma I I can't say
beyond that but I do know that I'm
pretty close to getting you to that
answer all right well we found a hunting
Tower number three I know I was here
okay
it's uh here take this other first-aid
kit because I got a feeling that you're
gonna need it all right I'm starting to
suspect that I am also the meat yeah
well you might be if you keep this up
but for the time being let's try to find
meat so that you don't have to be the
meat understood okay okay good good
we're a team here we're buddies were
pals we're in this together
that's right it's it's we're getting
what now you're not filling me with
confidence here man I need you to focus
stay on task we're getting wet but
that's okay it happens I'm rain fall
from sky sometime okay that was just a
tree I thought something was behind us
God how many times do I need to tell you
the trees are not out to get us man it's
okay you can relax around the trees all
right okay good thank you
who's a big boy not me what who's a big
man that's me
that's you you're a big man and you're
gonna get this Bigfoot a big man for a
Bigfoot uh-huh yep okay that's lunch and
dinner what I hear a lot of noise
what do you hear - sounds like a drum oh
that was us walking on the wood oh come
on don't be a silly Billy you're a big
man I'm sorry I forgot I had a peg leg
no that was you do wait no you're just
lying to me you don't have a peg leg at
all I only see one leg so I think I have
a peg low yeah oh my god you're like a
you have the object permanence of a baby
I don't know other leg when it must be a
peg leg no that's not how keep your head
together you got to keep it again you're
the only other human that I have in
these woods I need you to be there for
me okay
okay good okay you're feeling you're
feeling good you feel good you feel
or I feel whole now that you just told
me I don't have a peg leg so all right
good I'm glad you feel whole you
couldn't have chosen more disturbing
wording for that but I'm glad you feel
whole
seems like you're running away from me
right now no I'm just trying to pick up
the pace a little bit we got a lot of
ground to cover there were
whoa whoa where is it
yeah whatever it's fun if it if it gets
closer we'll we'll shoot it we're near
the we're near the other camp
stay close you wouldn't want to get
separated what do we have here get some
signal more always ah here's more
bullets take these bullets and if you
want a night-vision camera you can have
that one go for it Oh what was that you
take those players that were down here
yeah I took those there was something I
heard so I heard it you know there's
another battery here on the ground where
I'm at awesome all right got it take its
meat take its sweet delicious meat sweet
succulent delectable meat don't eat it
I've done it
I just have it good you need to save
that for Bigfoot here take this
night-vision battery oh I thought I
thought you're about to give me another
beer oh no you know we're will we'll
celebrate for a job well done once we
get too big you are you're really
jumping into that tent I'm there's a
trap in here and I'm trying to get it
I'm too tall I'm just too tall how do I
I can't crouch there's a left old or
left control oh oh okay oh hang on I
need to set up a trap I need to set up a
trap like immediately oh god oh god oh
god hey I got to put meat I got a mask
it okay back off from the trap just move
away from the trap you
I heard him from southwest turn off your
light farther Hey you see where I am
come over to me I'm coming
there's no jokey time this is serious
business okay just keep your eye on that
trap if he lands on it pepper him as
hard as you can try for headshots and
he will charge us afterward I will chase
him off with a flare but you just got to
keep nailing him no matter what so it's
becoming day yeah okay I don't know if
he's coming this way let's just hope
that was me let's go this way there's
another location up here let's just go
up there first if he hits that trap
that's great but if he doesn't that's
good too that trap will still be there
and it'll be okay okay did we did we not
need to plant cameras to watch it no no
we're fine
there's no point in watching a trap
whether he hits it or not as in
determine of whether like we won't be
there by the time he gets back ooh hello
ultra night-vision camera for me thank
you very much okay there's another
there's more stuff up here I don't know
what that location was but that's not
where we're headed you know where we're
headed
looks like up top to the ridge of the
hill Mountain I mean that's technically
a correct answer but it was more of an
ambiguous question we're headed into the
belly of the beast
we're heading to its home yes Wow you
got it
Wow those Eureka I thought I was being
pretty obscure with belly of the beast
but no you got it okay I mean the belly
means where they eat so I would think oh
the belly of the beasts
okay here's more bullets you take those
bullets and just remember you're gonna
be peppering him like nobody's ever been
peppered oh yeah I mean man he he likes
to eat on that rock yeah you Willy like
see pretty much everywhere and for some
reason he likes exclusively human flesh
and and I don't want to be the next
human flesh you know what I mean
I mean arguably we as a species are
overpopulated so oh maybe maybe it's
just we're easier prey are you literally
volunteering right now for the good of
the human species at reducing the
population are you volunteering to be
eaten by Bigfoot no no no no I'm just
I'm just simply saying that we have so
bad
oh shoot keep shooting
okay hey he did not like that we went to
his house no he definitely uninvited
guests yeah no we were not
okay so lesson learned literally don't
stop shooting I kept shooting did you
read it here it took a while to reload
well you didn't fill up your gun no I
filled up my gun it was just it was just
it's a bold action you know well bolt
faster oh I'll try I'll try so we uh we
only have a limited amount of flare so
you see the bar at the top I've got a
psychic connection with his help oh
you're slightly wounded I'll try to
maintain the connection as much as I can
it's such a strainer please do like we
hit them maybe four times yeah head
shots I think do more damage so just try
to pepper him with those okay usually if
you hit him he doesn't come immediately
back he kind of runs away so I think
we've got a little bit of time also you
lied to me Oh Bigfoot
what don't run and there he goes okay
and and and okay that sucked
he's real pissed yeah him in the head a
couple of times
ah okay it didn't seem like hey Cheston
a different maybe go for body shots
oh maybe why did he come for us like
that I'm gonna set down another trap
alright cuz you want me to heal you no
I'm fine I'm just only slightly bleedy
i I got beat twice he hit me into the
ground and just like ground pounded me
yeah he likes to do that he really likes
the whole ground pound you know I
thought he'd like a different style but
I mean I guess if they like it if he
likes it on top he likes it on top I
can't dude don't make this sexual why
you gotta make everything sexual I mean
I can't get this trap ready okay fine
we're fine we're fine he he was just
yelling oh he hit the other trap look
his health went down oh yes okay good
job good job thank you thank you very
much that was all me 100% also he might
be coming straight for us after this but
I put that other trap there so hopefully
he's not that's the only thing that I
got to hope for I mean does he have a
psychic connection to our location as
well he might because I think this
psychic connection goes both ways I'm
pretty sure that if I can know what his
health is he knows exactly where we are
at any given time okay so we get to know
his health he gets to know where we are
yeah pretty much yeah yeah pretty much
can he get into these towers probably
how much bullets do you have I have 21
bullets okay and I just reloaded so I
have a full clip of 10 okay you so you
have 10 and 21 on the side no
technically I have 10 and then 15 on the
side okay you keep you keep wool oh no
no he hit the other he hit the other go
get those bullets I'm gonna set out
another trap we're just gonna keep
moving get up that Tower
and I'm gonna set down another trap this
Sallah
not there Oh robot man you're fine
you're fine you're fine yeah we got to
keep moving come on we got to hit the
next spot before he gets on to us and
knows what we're up to
oh [ __ ] this class
thank you Thank You Tyler you're so
goddamn observant aren't you yes but how
do we get down from the left I think we
got a head towards the eastern so yeah
down here okay here all right I hate to
say this but we need to go into the
woods it's fine look it is very okay
are there no Gators on this swamp no no
no not every swamp has Gators in it but
I do think that the Bigfoot uses this as
his personal latrine that's why the
water looks kind of yellow yeah it's a
little poopy Oh God okay he hit the
other trap he's such an idiot this guy's
an idiot this guy's so stupid I think
the traps do more damage than are done
they do yeah they do problem I'm out of
traps I have one okay I wish I could
give it to you because you are more
skilled in the trapping
oh it's fine here I'll teach it's baby's
first trap okay all right all right so
come outside come outside Widow what is
this whoa okay we found Jack Martin all
right oh well all right better put a
trap right over his body all right
oh you got it okay put a trap right
there yeah that's good okay now when you
look at the trap press e on put meat got
it okay and then don't ask it now I'll
mask it for you I don't think you have
any what was that I don't know okay all
right let's back off from here let's
back off let's go to the other side of
the water right here and what we're
gonna do is we are gonna sit and we're
gonna watch that trap from the top of
this hill okay all right from this rock
right here I think this is a good
vantage point to spot him because we
need to recover the traps is the main
issue that we're having we're yet right
here okay you got a good view on it I
honestly don't see the trap from my meal
I think we're blocked by a tree okay
maybe let's hop down from here up there
it is okay I see it you see if you're
right here you can see you're the things
icon so yep I see it our hope is he's
gonna go to that trap
eat the meat and while he's stuck we're
gonna shoot the hell out of them
get as much damage in as possible and
then I will scare him away at the last
second okay and then we will run grab
the trap and then move on to the next
area
alright so turn him into [ __ ] God
god you wasted my heart Oh God oh oh oh
[ __ ] what was that if he comes here from
your bullet I swear to God um yeah I I
have my finger off of the trigger now I
see him he's on the far side he's going
straight for the meat okay he's going
straight nope he's going away
where's go I think he's going for the
meat okay get ready trained your gun I
see him he's I'm not sure if he's coming
closer come farther away this is what
separates the boys from the men
all right I'm watching the trap you're
watching him right I don't see him
anymore he went off do Wes who [ __ ] oh
jeez ignoring this that wait don't move
don't move do not move he is right on
the other side of this hill don't move
are you crouched I am crouched good
don't move a muscle
oh that's not a good sign was that a
mating call why is everything a mating
call to you why he used to easily grouse
that was a different noise it was a wolf
oh that didn't sound like a walk to me
well I mean I can't help that okay I
don't know what happened to him he was
literally right here and he's gone that
is the cream oh god I see him
okay he's either coming right for me oh
god is he coming right for me wait wait
don't move don't move no he's going for
it he's going for he's going for it get
ready I see it come on aim oh he's
coming towards us no he's not he's
thrown away like a [ __ ] outside of him
because the hill Reggie were on I got I
can see him for miles breath
alright I'm running to get the trap
alright yeah you go get the trap that
was good
we peppered him a lot we got a lot of
damage in the only problem is we don't
have nearly enough ammo it's not letting
me pick up the truck why not
it's broken what you missed bro oh yeah
oh you right oh you right oh [ __ ] okay
let's move we got a boogie then okay
that means every trap that we had is
gone yeah okay that's a problem that's
what you call a problem I is there a way
to solve it though hidden traps
elsewhere we'll figure it out man we
will figure it out you and me we
together on this
I think it's foots too big and that's
what's causing the traps to break you
know you might be right that might be
the smartest thing you've said all day
[ __ ] oh God
turn off your light turn off your light
god damn it Jessie him he's just walking
I've never seen him just walk before but
he's just walking you just keep it quiet
we're gonna go south there was another
area up there but I'm gonna say screw
that cuz it was another cave and I think
he's going back to his cave duh lick his
wounds among other things
wonder how intelligent he is if he has
first aid kits to use for himself man I
I threw you a real softball sexual
innuendo there and you just you didn't
take it at all no you see I have to
create them and then you yell at me for
it for them that's that's how this
partnership works I just ignore anything
else that comes out why does that have
to be the way that it is who read up on
that so I'm just to be subjected to be
your horrible innuendos yes
have we been here before no we have
remember this I remember a fence so you
remember a fence
you remember one fence yes I mean we ran
into a fence earlier I thought that
might be it it wasn't so I made a
mistake
you know I can't fault you for that
logic and you you did own up to your own
mistake so I guess I can't make fun of
you no I'm actually gonna make fun of
you I'm gonna make funny that is rabb
solutely ridiculous they would think in
an entire forest just because you see a
fence twice at oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] my dude
my dude my dude is my main man oh [ __ ]
can you not get us
I don't think here oh yeah always
breaking the down he's breaking it down
oh god he broke it down okay I'm gonna
try it oh [ __ ]
Oh get him off me oh please okay I feel
bad okay yeah dog I tracked him just let
him go my ribs are kind of exploded all
right just follow me all of hey he hurts
so awesome yeah well how about here's
the first aid kit cuz ouch
are you uh when should I use first-aid
kit I'm at half health you can take a
few more Wallops I think unless you're a
big baby most curious um you know some
Eagle Scout who can't even take a few
wounds listen we were trained to not
take once Wow
you don't even know when to take a
first-aid kit oh yeah you can throw in
your badges looking to buy 22 bullets by
the way that's good keep those around
I'm gonna see if tracking bullets do any
damage because I'm not a hundred percent
sure if they do I love it video they
should they should do like a tiny bit
yeah like half games if you look in the
bottom left you can see a glowing red
button dot do you see that uh I do not
what oh now I do yes
yeah so that's Bigfoot right now and by
the looks of it Bigfoot yes which is a
problem why is that a problem
because he hits us he does he does hit
us he does I open this door yeah let's
go inside all right we got good guard
trap okay how many bullets you got to
take those 22 take them I've got an even
better idea than we had previously what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna set a trap
right out here with some tasty delicious
meat and we're gonna go in that cabin
yeah you feelin me yeah I feel you I
feel you we're gonna sit there with the
door open and our guns trained on it our
lights off okay you're in charge of
closing
door okay all right so I have to hit Yi
on the door yes you do you're gonna
close that door and there's no way that
he could bash down the door to a cabin
right no there's no way that'd be
ridiculous a crouch man be one with the
woods feel it you feel it I I do but if
art be one with the woods when I'm
inside no well I mean you're inside a
log cabin it was made of trees it is
pretty much of the woods but that it's
there dead trees well I mean okay I
thought you didn't like trees anyway
like you hunted trees
no no I've seen loggers do that I never
said I did that I just I just I just
said I don't had some people okay all
right agree to disagree we got a problem
because the tracking went away and
there's a storm rolling in yeah and for
some reason it's raining blood so he
either could be right around the corner
or going in a completely different
direction than we would know neither of
the truth well I guess this is the part
where we just we just stakeout yeah
sparing that state gonna stake out
that's good that's clever you should put
that on a shirt okay okay okay you know
I'm really curious why somebody decided
to store their acts like that
um maybe they were bored and they were
trying to throw from that chair
Oh see he's coming he's coming he's
coming he's going for it oh I see him oh
he ran away oh the big [ __ ] baby
oh wait is he has he gotten too clever
for this I'm gonna go maybe he wanted
the the cover for of the hunt maybe dark
net maybe maybe baby I'm gonna go out
there dinner yes sir my buttocks are
tasty so I wonder if I could fit my
entire arm up Bigfoot's ass you know I
wonder if you could fit your entire body
based on his size and it's fun it's
possible I bet if I get a running start
and I like dive like swan dive in
hand-over-hand I bet I can make it
inside like at least up to my waist I
feel like if you had a train
you could get pull on well how would
that work he would have to be like
laying on the ground but cheeks up kind
of like spreading his cheeks for a
trampoline to give any tangible benefit
maybe maybe a view swan dive off that
cliff while he's like a sleep honest on
it's on his head doing a handstand right
okay okay so we just got to give him to
fall asleep in a handstand bring a
trampoline next to him bounce high
enough such that I can swan dive down
and then enter into his anus yes or just
have him fall asleep handstand leaning
against the cliff side and jump off the
cliff that is also very creative a
thought this out all right let's move on
before we get even further damndest here
there's a mine right around the corner
from here we gotta go check it out it's
right here I'm hoping they're more trap
ah
we shall see the answer to that question
is no for some reason all it's giving us
is night-vision cameras why do we need
this many night-vision cameras I mean I
guess it makes sense that a night-vision
camera would be in a mine and not traps
yeah I guess I don't know man it just
doesn't add up we got to make our ways
to this shelter over here it's just down
the way and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna circle back to base camp after
this because we'll have gathered pretty
much everything up into this point
manage rain is loud if there's a shelter
first thing God so we don't need to give
us bullets what is this this is like the
worst rng I've ever seen in my entire
life we don't have any bullets take that
first aid I swear to god it's like it
doesn't want us to have bullets I don't
think it does I don't think it wants the
stab traps at all either
no it doesn't we've had like a complete
absence of traps bullets everything that
we could possibly need to actually
survive is just missing what is
happening to my frames I'm jittery oh
why you got bad friends yeah yeah trap
oh god oh god oh god go away I don't
know if the dragon bullets hurt because
I couldn't look at the time
god damn it oh I am so stuttery right
now well stop it stop being stuttering
okay good news is we got more bullets
here take these bullets here I got one
from the backpack their daddy sucks he
really kind of snuck up on us right here
he sucks at least I got him with a
tracking bullet I don't know what did
help signal flares for I don't know I
don't know try it next time he charges
our buttholes alright it's fine how many
bullets you got total 40 okay I've got
15 regular bullets and 17 tracking
bullets I don't know if the dragon
bullets hurt him at all I feel like they
should I feel like that's only fair but
I don't know so it is what it is I mean
like I am no no stutter woof woof okay
is this a real wolf are wolves real in
this game Oh Fox Fox got it oh nice Adam
give your meat give me your sweet
delicious meat all right he's on me he's
far away right now yeah he's pretty far
away quick is this like a haunted part
of the woods why's that leaves all gone
from these trees yeah this is there's an
operative tree - what the hell I've
never seen this part of the woods before
oh that's weird
oh they're burnt oh oh well that doesn't
necessarily mean that it could be many
things why would they be burnt just
because of a fire it could have been
roasted really badly in like some insult
contest
now that Edward that's good let's say we
can pick them up why's there dot on them
I just kind of identify okay there were
just some bullets I took them to even us
out okay there's only one other spot
that we could possibly go to
it looks like Bigfoot is heading towards
us
yeah well okay I don't like it but yeah
you seem to be right and you want to
drop a trap somewhere yeah I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna do it over in this
clearing over here along the road right
about Oh Tracking's gone that's okay
it's okay it's okay hey man chill man
just relax why you why you so peeved
listen bud get to the top of the hill
bud okay so we should just be able to
see oh [ __ ] I hear he's coming for us
nothing keeps Krusemark he's too smart
okay god I wish not miss hey can you
stop that all right use first aid now
now well I don't know why he didn't go
for the goddamn trap probably cuz he
sucks and he's stupid and very dumb
their way to pause cuz I need I need to
use the facilities why do you need to
use the facilities there's no way to
pause this has been for time oh okay
okay go go I'll guard your body or
something I don't know okay I'm gonna
set a trap I I guess just make sure you
don't set your character in the middle
of the gods who did you you set yours up
in the middle of the road you stupid
Isaac I'm afraid that he's kind of
stupid this is fine fellas Bigfoot's
halfway dead that's a small consolation
price
Oh God walls just here alone
contemplating my feelings it's gonna
drink you back nope okay he's going for
a poopy oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I saw him he was
right there he was right there he was
right there I saw him why would he just
stick his head up why would Bigfoot just
do that did it work did I scare him away
yeah Jesus why over number one why did
you park yourself in the middle of the
street
number two yeah he was here he picked
his head up and then went away he picked
his head up right between the trees that
I'm looking at and then he just went
away oh I don't think he's gonna be
tricked by the traps anymore I think
he's wise mmm he's wise to the traps now
yeah I know I don't know what else to do
about it unless like we can get him to
run over the traps you know by us kinda
being the bait and yea yea yea cuz if we
set him up in a line and then just kind
of blah I'm dead
right no heart if this was deer hunter
game I would doubt be a good hit give me
the meat your your meat sweet succulent
meat we could also just put meat on the
ground I guess and hope that he gets
good goes for it that makes sense that
just be like baiting the hook and we are
the the hook we're the folks yeah we're
the hooks yeah we're the hooks we're
going right in his mouth yeah big food
we're going in your mouth with a hooks
right right buddy yeah we're gonna we're
gonna get you from the inside yeah your
insides are ours yeah I'm gonna climb in
your butthole I'm gonna go in your ear
and yeah shoot nothing yeah with ecstasy
I mean with fear you're gonna go in from
the mouth I'm gonna go in through the
anus we're gonna meet in the middle
that's that's a new kind of hug
it's a hug from the inside best kind of
last four years not just seconds last
until the day you die
which will be soon oh look a cab oh hey
buddy hey how you doing who's this Emily
Jones Wow Emily you're beautiful okay
looks like there's rifle bullets and
that's literally it
I have 37 so you should grab it okay
yeah 37 well all right so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna go back way the
way we came and we're gonna try to find
some of our old traps because I want to
see if they're all broken because I
don't think it's a guarantee that
they'll be broken I think it's just kind
of likely would you say it's highly
likely somewhat like oh no to be
perfectly honest I really don't know how
are you gonna complete the survey if you
can't answer one of the survey questions
I mean it what are you the official
survey taker now I can't I can't be
bothered to do it I haven't it I don't
have enough as a statistical sample I
just you know I just felt like it needed
to be answered and you just you just I
don't think you can fail a survey but I
think you somehow managed to do that
what are you the master of surveys now
what makes you in charge listen I filled
out a ton of surveys in my day
uh-huh and I mean I I was asking you and
giving you the survey so that would make
me set master of that survey so I shot a
raccoon nice thank you can you like a
Coonskin hat I do not want to why not I
wanted to be I want to make Bigfoot
boots that I mean that makes sense
Thanks that's that's the that's the true
game by like oh I forgotten there's
there's one other location we haven't
been we've been to the cave yet we
haven't been inside the cave yes there's
a cave it's Bigfoot's cave
does that mean it's Cave of Wonders or
it depends on what you mean by wonders
like treasure behold it Wow okay no the
opposite
what's opposite of treasured cornice oh
no I'm touching poorness it's everywhere
in this case
oh no that's what it is it's bill see
it's full of bills oh god it's the lower
middle class in here Oh God people below
the poverty line oh hey I never said I
had an issue with those people I said I
had an issue with the whole poverty guys
at home can you believe that Tyler hates
poor people no they can't believe it
you're right they cannot believe it they
expected better of you makes sense we
can't all be caricatures of epicness
yeah we can't all be lovers of these
poor people someone has to hate them and
tell them what for the Sun is rising
no the Sun is rising or is is falling oh
it's rising yeah I was hoping it was
rising because it was dark before I
don't know would it just become doubly
dark ah double dark the internet
couldn't handle that much dark applier
so I don't know double D from Ed Edd and
Eddy oh it's like some kind of double D
if you know what I'm talking about
Winkley oh yeah yeah all right if it's
in a threeway oh yeah what yeah double D
2 to ds-11 me ah the name of my favorite
porno 2 DS 1 me hey I think this is
actually the last body that we need to
define Wow why just want to eat the face
probably because we put more lotion on
the face because we want to prevent
aging I don't know if that would make it
more attractive to eat I feel like
eating lotion wouldn't be too appetizing
I mean but it means it's moistening it
and you know you don't like dry me you
don't like like me like well-done you
like a medium-rare right I mean you're
right about that but I don't think
lotion is gonna get the same effects as
medium-rare now if we massage the face
then maybe yeah you might have a point
there hey okay so it's time to make our
stand
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's coming
I mean you check out Rebecca understand
oh my god okay single Claire and what
the hell oh god I miss Oh dying
I had full health before that is he mad
at you or something you're dying yes
yeah I don't know why I didn't hear
anything to him okay I tracked him he's
not going very far where is he where is
it what why he's just kind of stuck okay
let's go this way come here we're
running away from him he's a bad bad boy
and we got to get away what does the
signal flare do
all right this of no use to anybody
maybe that's how you get him to chase
you oh like t-rex oh yeah yeah well I
can wave it like this I'm glad you can't
burn the forest down because I would
probably kill us too I'm a little sad
about that to be perfectly honest so we
have found everywhere there are items
and we are we no longer harvest items
yes so this is where things get a little
dicey he's got about half health we I've
got two traps do you have any traps left
I have zero traps all right good okay oh
we're doing good we're doing good buddy
we're doing good I think I set a trap
down over here but doesn't seem to be
like this remember where you set it yeah
it would show up on the as an icon on
the ground if it was usable all right so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna go
back to base okay sound good sounds
fabulous we're gonna go back to base and
we're gonna formulate a plan we're gonna
Scout and we're going to destroy okay
yes I'm just trying to catch up right
now hurry up use guten loser
I cut a bear whoa whoa whoa that's a
barrel I hear it's definitely a bear oh
it's coming this way oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
shoot it shoot it shoot it shoot it
shoot God what raccoon why raccoon just
jumped out over there what yeah well
just ran up out of the Bears mouth are
you saying that bear was pregnant with a
raccoon that's what apparently happened
because there was definitely a raccoon
that took off you know I'm a little
confused by that that seems unlikely
oh [ __ ] that oh he's caught he's a
common he he's coming he's Bigfoot's on
the way he's common why is there another
red dot I accidentally shot the bear all
right so what we're gonna do is I'm
gonna set these traps down I'm gonna
mask them a get on the other side of
this these traps right he's on the
Brooklyn way oh god here he here he come
I'm gonna stand right next to these so
if he's coming for me he's got to hit
these he's has to hit these traps well
he's dead ahead
oh I don't have your name icon anymore
mind you look I'm right here what all
right here you're not here I'm right
next to you okay I'm right next to just
trust we can't see any more I'm a ghost
listen compiler listen oh you have
monkey fighting I'll be by your side
unlike your stand
do you know what that means I don't know
what that noise means it's the bull it's
a wolf
you stupid you've heard him before well
he broke one of the traps apparently yes
you did
and he might be busting I can't see you
I can only hear you live you're like
microwaved the bass go to the baby's
beautiful sounds great don't worry we
have enough me I can see you on the
mini-map but I can't see you in person
well this is a bit of a problem I bet
one Bigfoot comes by again you're gonna
see my corpse on his hands your friend
this is what you get for threatening to
trampling inside my [ __ ] don't even
come near me with her inside hog
glorious I don't think that could
qualify as glorious oh I found a deer
should I shoot it too late all right you
got it hesitation goes half the battle
ghost man the deer just died out of
nowhere dad it really alright we're
almost back to base once we're there we
are safe and sound my friend did you
know that we will be safe and sound I
did not know that see it's cuz it's a
lie we will not be safe and we will not
be sound but the good news is he is more
than halfway dead we are very close to
getting this Bigfoot bagged how many
bullets you got I got 19 okay I've got
11 plus some tracking bullets I don't
know if the dragon bullets do anything
what I've got them maybe there's like
some more bullets in here that we
overlooked or something yeah we left the
truck running wow we're smart
Oh another trap there's another trap ooh
I wonder if if we pick up another gun I
wonder if a gun comes preloaded with
bullets I think it does maybe we will
find out later okay here's the deal
there used to be an act
where you get on top of the the RV and
shoot them from there but we're not
gonna do that you know why cuz we're too
good exactly we are too good honestly I
didn't expect you to even answer that
question properly but I'm glad that you
did so what we're gonna do I have two
traps you have no traps you said I have
no traps okay that's fine
what we're gonna do is we are going to
shoot and shoot and shoot and shoot and
shoot until he's dead and then all we
got to do is hit him with two more traps
shooty shooty shooty shooty and then
bada bing bada boom
he'll be dunzo ones oh yeah you feel
wish I could look at you when you're
talking but you see the magical traps
appearing out of nowhere actually I'm
gonna do this one trap is there do not
step on it one trap is over here you
stand by this trap that I just placed
down you see it I only see the one trap
okay you stand by a trap I'll stand by
another trap and then when he gets close
we're gonna lay into it and just
whatever direction he's coming from
walked to the other side of the trap and
get him to walk into it you understand
yes okay cool
I'm gonna put meat on the ground around
here just to bring him out Bigfoot
premiere Bigfoot I've got a face for you
to eat I've got a better face my face is
way better than his face mine's clean
[Applause]
what about my face my face is gonna you
know when you watched it last
I watched nice morning I washed it this
morning I bet I did it before you
I laid in a red-lit bed of sorts that's
good for the skin that is weird
that's just weird why do you do that why
would you do that good for the skin you
don't know that where is it good for the
skin his science says so what signs
how many peer-reviewed articles have
there been that says it's sitting in a
bath of red light it's good to click it
I have not looked for a peer-reviewed
hey okay I don't think he liked coming
near the camp for some reason you know I
think you upset him when you said he's
not getting the hug he doesn't want a
hug no one would want the hug the hog is
a horrible thing yeah well you have you
met Bigfoot if you have you actually
talked with him and had a nice meal with
him I've been
having intimate conversations ever since
my body went away hey can you see me no
I just I just I'm shining a light on you
because I know you're over by that trap
who was that noise I didn't hear
anything do you hear something I heard
something what did you hear
looks like a weird crunching chirp sound
a crunching chirp sound okay that's
really distinct and helpful um like what
like like look like a Tweety Bird that
just got stepped on oh that's sad
okay I mean he really doesn't want to
come hang out with us today yeah he
doesn't like the camp I'm thinking cuz
he was all over us a little bit ago but
if we go to the main camp I guess it's a
little little too our territory for his
tastes oh I see him what was where okay
get him on that travel get him on that
trap get him on that no oh god oh god no
not today not today oh did he just blog
with a signal flare I hit him with a
signal flare alright alright alright oh
yeah he got real damage watch out for
the trap over here where to go that's
why oh I took it that's right I took it
okay that was good that was good that
was real good he is almost dead how much
bullet you got left 13 okay I've got
tracking bullets and two normal bullets
left and that's it so this is for all
the beans then this is alright I should
heal cuz I have one more first aid kit
left do you need heals no I've got no
first-aid kits but that's okay because
I'm gonna be better about the signal
flare this time around I was pretty late
on the signal flare where's the where's
the trap I've got it I've got one last
trap do you know where I am
you still don't see me I still don't see
you you are literally the only reason I
knew Bigfoot was coming this cuz I
literally saw your name coming at me you
get it cuz I'm inside of his anus I get
it you get it I get it
didn't we find everybody Thomas right
yes it says fine lost people four out of
four it's checked off on my tablet yeah
it's not checked off on here
spooky guitar I really wish you could
see my perspective it is so great
alright let's finish this vitamin dude
sounds fabulous
uh actually before we do that number one
I'm gonna set a trap right at the door
here and then I must set out a drone
because I'm going to take this up and
I'm gonna Scout must count around Wow
I'm hoping that I'm gonna find like some
unknown area that doesn't necessarily
show up on my other map here and is like
someplace with ammo or another trap if
we could just get like another box of
bullets maybe one more trap I think
we've got this guaranteed as if an
unknown kitten oh we did that's unknown
cave the lair I remember going to my
miners house shelters yeah everything
that's on the map we've been to that's
what we've discovered looking for any
like landmarks or anything that could be
some kind of something that would hide
an ammo drop I'm not seeing much of
anything then again it's hard to know
exactly what I'm looking for but we did
find some things that weren't named
locations that had items I'm just hoping
to luck out and get another one yeah oh
here's a lake I don't know nice lake
this lake is lovely what's better than
that swamp ooh wait I found canoes is
that a box of bullets I've got eyes on a
box of bullets okay let me look at the
map I'm trying to memorize where this is
okay I know where this is
that's I'm looking at it to you you got
it oh yeah you know where the drone is
okay okay yeah this is where the bullets
are alright did you pick up the trap
where I did I did I did I'm headed
towards where the drone is you see me on
the map I see you on the map I am
following I've got the flare gun out so
if he comes by I'm gonna try to shoot
him right away
alright get the signal flare out maybe
that would be better I believe I have
one of those okay I don't know if this
is gonna help get your signal for Wolf
Wolf Wolf Wolf Wolf Den
PAH okay good news tracking bullets
apparently do kill all right
yeah you have some tracking bullets
right yeah I have 10 okay good that
means that we got a little extra bullet
for our killing buddy I believe in us
I wholeheartedly think we we can bag
this Bigfoot we're gonna bag this
Bigfoot
we're gonna put him in a big bag a body
bag you know why you know why we need to
prove he exists and by doing that he
must be dead
right yeah sure let's go with that
Nesbitt eco-terrorists but you know okay
I'm all for it yeah let's kill this
Bigfoot okay it's on the other side of
this highly dangerous waterfall uh watch
your step
ah I found it alright guy go for a
little swim oh it is deep in this water
here yeah okay here's the bullets
alright you you can have the bullets
right here over by this yellow kayak
that's it yeah I'm gonna set the trap
out for you just so you can have it here
and run and bring a run around rosy and
I'm gonna Scout a few more spots with
the drone okay off I go oh great I can't
see anything cuz it's night okay I can't
see anything I don't know if there's oh
wait what is that is that a table no
Bigfoots overhead [ __ ] okay where where
he's I'm facing him okay he's on the
other side he's walking on him yep okay
he's coming this way he's coming
where is he serious yeah oh he's running
he's running
it's alright we got we got three hits on
him now and I got a tracking bullet on a
man also by the way it shows your
flashlight his body is with you I'm
swimming across I'm going down south of
his I saw a picnic table over here it
might have something on it tracking more
off not for me I see him I'll let you
know if he's on the way picnic table
please tell me there's something on the
picnic table so he can't swim he had to
run around pass stupid okay there's
nothing on the picnic table god damn it
this is honestly a good point because he
can only come from one direction uh I
love that band yes shame about the
break-up wait they broke up am I am I
not in the loop
no they're together what are you talking
about story of my life
nayad keep her warm spend on my logic
take her home yeah I hate to break it
you see this no no they're broken up
there they're lost on it they're like
jelly beans come on I'm PG Oh doing it
Lobby I've dropped a lot of f-bombs I'm
sorry ah he's a little far away he's
coming back towards us I'm back over
here I'm gonna put the trap down again
yeah he has to come from that direction
to get to us from here right right this
is this is a good a good position oh he
is coming towards us yeah I'm gonna put
them some meat down just to slap her on
the ground and maybe it'll be a little
more attractive what's that tasty
delicious meat oh come on show me show
me Mark's body do it oh he's done he's
coming he's coming he's coming straight
down this way he's on the other side of
the pond I see him he's running oh I see
em I see your flashlight okay yeah now I
see your name he's coming this way
coming right for us there is got him oh
he's not going for the trap what are you
dead I'm not dying I don't have another
first-aid kit I have a first-aid kit I
can't give it to you though okay imma
take you have no it says you have no
items what I have items it says you have
no items did you see all my items no I
don't have a first-aid kit
you ever first-aid kit I I did I had one
left no I I shot him twice
with the flare gun the second time it
just didn't go off no no you wait you
should be able to heal yourself baby my
inventory shows is empty - oh you're all
up in me uh did you die it still says
I'm dying I'm not quite dead yet but I'm
I'm probably close no no please he hit
me with your corpse and it took me out I
didn't want this to be this way
alright I will avenge you with the two
bullets I have left
oh I'll get him all right where is he
get him it get him in that trap - I see
him
oh yeah he he's he's running around the
pond
okay I'm completely out of bullets all I
got left is a signal flare baby are you
burning light am on fire
I got a knife - I'm gonna go for the
night gonna nice nice nice oh [ __ ] oh oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god I'm up
I'm up
I don't have to go anymore
hey yay you're you were attached to him
for the longest time Wow hey buddy hey
wow that was a crazy nap I just took
yeah how are you doing you don't look so
good oh [ __ ] he's coming back I only
have one leg on my screen yeah oh yeah
I'll put a peg leg in Jaeger your stick
but we did find this area which actually
is a really good vantage point to fight
him because you know yeah man oh we're
so close so I know are you dead yet no
I'm still says I'm dying
no can you can you finish me off with a
knife or something I don't know I'll try
how's that feel is that good oh no no
I'm seeing blood I'm seeing blood I've
seen a lot of bud maybe right here know
is there a way to finish myself off try
leaving the game maybe that'll drop your
animus for you are you out of the game I
am out of the game no your body's still
here can I rejoin and be a different
person
yes try to rejoin are you backing your
corpse yes
I'm sad I know we were so close next
time was next time maybe we'll get the
whole gang and maybe that way it'll
spawn more items because I feel like we
were getting really cheated with the
number of bullets and such and
definitely number of traps we barely got
any trash yeah I remember getting a lot
more traps last time next time the whole
gang will be here and we will show
Bigfoot who is the ballast I'm gonna
walk slowly over the waterfall and I'll
see you around okay Yama
well I'm not going yet I'm still still
walking towards the water boy I'm
stay I haven't gone anywhere yet I'm
about to I see you swimming good that's
great
yeah I'm gonna I'll be see your eye here
I go
almost enjoy the fall 3 2 1
I'm too tired I can't run ok here we go
going and through Oh God celebrate he's
celebrating he's having a feast yeah
yeah yeah our faces are gone
god dammit we'll get you next time until
next time goodbye
[Music]